malheureusement ces médicaments ne sont
pas couverts d'emblée par la régie de
l'assurance maladie
le docteur pinard averti son patient
elle demandera la ramq d'approuver un
nouveau médicament pour traiter ses
douleurs causées par un cancer mais la
réponse pourrait se faire attendre avant
d'avoir une acceptation on peut même
atteindre des fois c'est 7 9 mois est ce
qu'on peut légitimement à accepter que
pendant six mois
oui moi une demande très nette les
délais semblent de plus en plus l'on
constate aussi le docteur drew pinsky
sans parler du temps perdu au téléphone
pour parler un préposé ajoute ce
pharmacien notamment pour avant l'année
les demandes particulières à la régie
ont explosé il s'agit surtout de
patients qui ne répondent pas aux
traitements standards ou pour lesquels
un médicament ne figurent pas sur les
listes prêt à prouver
radio canada a appris que deux cent
soixante dix sept mille demandes
d'exception ont été formulées en 2017
c'est à dire 60 mille roquettes de plus
qu'il ya trois ans la régie ignore
pourquoi mais assure que les demandes
urgentes sont traités en 24 heures parce
que la dizaine de personnes qui vont
s'ajouter dans les prochaines semaines
pour pour l'équipe qui compte environ
présentant une quarantaine de personnes
font qu'on a eu la réponse aujourd'hui
les médecins et les pharmaciens ne
comprennent pas pourquoi les agents de
la ram qu sont disponibles seulement du
lundi au vendredi jusqu'à 16h30
le cabinet du ministre a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue
tout indique qu'il n'est pas question
pour l'instant d'augmenter les heures de
service
même si les professionnels de la santé
eux doivent le faire au bout de la ligne
je suis pas certaine que économiquement
on sauve beaucoup de sous en enfin le
les gens au mal des fois les gens sont
en arrêt de travail donc c'est pas
toujours très efficient et en attendant
c'est les patients qui se retrouve au
milieu parce que tant qu'ils n'ont pas
l'accès au remboursement parfois pendant
dé longs mois
ils sont en train de souffrir les
médecins se demande comment le ministre
baroud dont les réformes les oblige à
traiter davantage de patients a pu
ignorer le surcroît de demande
occasionnés à la régie lorsqu'il a mise
en place ces réformes pourquoi gaétan
barrette n'at-il pas lever tous les
obstacles administratifs
c'est la question que posent de nombreux
professionnels
senti que nous avons rencontrés selon
eux pour augmenter leur efficacité le
ministre n'aura pas choix d'optimiser
les services de la ram qu ici véronique
prince radio canada lévy